I swear to God this room is my tomb this
is where I'll come to die in this
freaking yoga mat room
I was feeling fine
and brain
I'm excited to like get back into the
swing of things because I know like my
mood it's gonna improve I mean I know
I'm gonna hate it like there's there's
no way around that
like I'll go to bed earlier and my skin
will get better I am most nervous about
just feeling and like a walking corpse
the benefits of exercise are like
endless so I just woke up I'm totally
don't do it for them because they're
stupid why would it be weird or bad if I
put cold brewed coffee in my water
bottle
absolutely well complete this morning so
now I'm rushing government so that I can
like not look like a slob when I go to
work
day two I just woke up and I hate this
three more days this
how are things going so far man how Oh
feel great I'm showing up increasingly
later to work over the course of the
week and I already show up late to begin
with working out in the morning is way
different than working out after work I
feel stressed for time and I'm a lot
more tired I feel better Pegasus been
kind of rewarding physically or whatever
pretty sure it may be work like wait 15
minutes later which is like me being 15
minutes early
in the beginning I was definitely way
more tired even though I worked out in
the morning and then towards the end I
did start to feel I think better I don't
know the difference was so subtle but it
did it did it easier to wake up early I
think the hardest part was just change I
guess the heart like I didn't know how
hard it would be to just like change
something that I do every day a
breakfast this forced me to eat
breakfast no I would not do this again
any better get health whenever that
matters but
I hated it I hated it I hated all of it